as they say there is only one poll that  counts and that is what happens on  Election Day we have a hundred days to  go and i think that the party i lead has  a very clear message which is we've got  a strong economic record we've turned  the country around we've created a  thousand jobs every day well I've been  based in this building as Prime Minister  the economy is growing unlike other  European countries we see success ahead  of us rather than continued failure and  we should build on that and the choice  is the competence we offer versus the  chaos of a Labour government or any of  the alternatives that would go back to  the bad old ways of more borrowing more  taxing more spending all the things that  got us into this mess in the first place  so it's going to be obviously a very  close and tough fight but I think we  have a really strong offer for our  countries think